enough talking let's see some games up
first we're headed to the Outlands
that's right it's Apex legends time
anyone want to take me out
[Music]
you should smile
hey apex fans the battle just keeps
getting bigger thanks to you
apex legends is coming off its most
successful most epic season yet and
we're just getting started
season 4 saw more of you jumping into
the fight than ever before and you've
kept that amazing momentum going forward
making season 5 the biggest and best
start to a season ever hold on to your
Holograms we hope you've been enjoying
season 5 fortunes favor which has seen
the introduction of our latest legend
lobha a major map change to Kings Canyon
rest in peace' skull town an all new
ranked series and a ton of quality of
life updates but it's about to get even
better today I'm here to tell you about
what's coming next - season 5 with our
latest collection event lost treasures
take a look
adventurous Raiders explores they risk
everything in such a fame fortune and
answers if you find what they're looking
for but if they survive they might walk
away with lost treasures
I'll high-five you all when I see you
mobile responding
register
guns these guns I don't need guns I know
what I'm looking for I won't walk away
without it Doris has a fire
as you just saw the lost treasures
collection event brings with it a ton of
great content including a new limited
time mode armed and dangerous' evolved
it's the return of a fan-favorite
snipers and shot he's only but with a
twist
sending out my decoy all armor is evil
armor and we're removing all of the
respawn beacons across the entire map
don't worry though you'll still be able
to bring back your teammates with the
help of a new item the mobile respawn
beacon you'll have one of these in your
inventory at the start of each match
giving you the power to choose win and
more importantly where you bring your
teammates back into the battle lost
treasures also introduces the new town
takeover cryptos map ring which gives
players a closer look at what motivates
this drone wielding hacker
and of course the lost treasures
collection delivers a bunch of exclusive
content you can earn by completing
challenges as well as all new event
exclusive cosmetic items and the
introduction of you boy mirages heirloom
which is fittingly a trophy of himself
excited to see you all on the ring don't
worry there's plenty of bees to go
around
crown and the best part is you don't
have to wait that long lost treasures
drops on Tuesday June 23rd and that's
not all apex fans the battle is
expanding that's right this fall we're
bringing apex legends to steam and I
know you're hoping wondering praying so
before you ask yeah cross play is coming
to apex this fall it's been one of the
biggest requests we get and we're
thrilled to finally deliver it to our
fans what am I forgetting oh yeah one
last thing let's make it official
we're huge fans of Nintendo here at
respawn and we're incredibly excited to
be bringing apex legends to the switch
this fall and we'll share more details
in the months ahead so that means you'll
be able to squad up no matter where are
you and your friends prefer to play xbox
playstation switch or on the PC via
Origen and steam we're throwing out a
lifeline and healing the divide between
the platforms on behalf of the entire
apex team we want to thank our
incredible community your passion for
the game is truly inspiring we look
forward to seeing you all in the arena
and don't forget check out lost
treasures on June 23rd
whoa man how is that me I think a cyber
but hyperbole boy I think I'm
hyperventilating